l'épidémie elle poursuit son
ralentissement le nombre de patients
hospitalisés en réanimation est en
baisse présents côté edouard philippe le
ministre de la santé a annoncé vouloir
généraliser les tests de dépistage dans
les établissements de santé pour
personnes âgées les familles auront
également un droit de visite dans les
ehpad pour faire le point avec nous sur
la situation on retrouve lit la femme
ouzou en direct de l'ehpad grenelle dans
le 15ème arrondissement de paris
il a fait un bon jour des mesures de
précaution très strictes seront donc
mises en place pour permettre ce retour
du droit de visite aux familles quelles
sont les conditions
effectivement des droits de visite qui
seront très encadré sous la
responsabilité des chefs
d'établissements des droits de visite
qui seront accordées à la demande du
président pas plus de deux membres de la
famille ne seront autorisées à rendre
visite aux personnes âgées
et puis le contact physique est toujours
interdite impossible donc de toucher les
membres de leur famille car a dit
olivier verrons l'objectif 1 est
toujours de trouver un équilibre entre
sécurité et maintien du lien social je
propose de l'écouter
tandis que le confinement est amenée à
durer encore pour plusieurs semaines
il nous a semblé utile de consulter à
nouveau les sociétés savantes les
représentants des organismes de ces
établissements pour personnes âgées et
nous avons élaboré ensemble des
recommandations nouvelles qui
permettront à partir de demain
d'organiser dans les territoires sous la
responsabilité des directions
d'établissement un droit de visite pour
les familles à direction direction de
leurs aînés fragile admis en ehpad
ce serait à la demande du résident ce
sera dans des conditions extrêmement
vous l'imaginez
limitez pas plus de deux personnes de la
famille à tout le monde en même temps ce
sera sous la responsabilité des
directions encore une fois
d'établissement qui devront dire à la
famille lorsque ce sera possible et dans
quelles conditions
sachant que la sécurité sanitaire
reste au coeur de notre projet et qu'il
y aura donc l'impossibilité maintenu
d'aller toucher la personne d'être en
contact physique par contre il y aura un
contact visuel
le ministre de la santé a également
annoncé que 5 millions de masques serait
déstocker il a reconnu qu'il y avait eu
des problèmes de en termes de protection
pour le personnel soignant
rappelons le un plus de 7000 personnes
dans les ehpad sont décédés depuis le
début de l'épidémie